okay hello everyone
welcome to a live stream
that um
is studying
the the basic computational
the basic computational something of
multi-computation
sort of a mixture of of science and
technology here
um all right we've got a number of
things we're going to talk about we
actually had backed into talking about
some of this
uh yesterday
uh in talking about how to scan a graph
but i think we're going to be covering
mostly different things today
so let's uh get into it
all right tracecraft and trace tree from
ian
um
let's see do you want to um
so these are now things in the function
repository is that correct
yes
and um
and and trace tree is something that we
haven't
properly reviewed aside from bringing it
up in the trees design review that we
needed to look at it again
could somebody uh just give me the the
multiply nested the nestle recursive
function that i seem to test this on
every time
um
do we do we have that we have that
anybody know what i'm talking about
ian do you know
i i remember i'll have to look for it
okay
all right i want to i want to make this
so
why is this trace graph okay so let's
make sure we understand what's happening
in stress graph
so we've got an expression
the dot dot dot means an evaluation red
dots mean an evaluation correct
yeah
okay
the
this thing means what it means a sub sub
expression that correct
yeah that's a subsidiary evaluation
so in a sense this is kind of drill down
into the expression
this is this is kind of an event
so nick and others i kind of want an
analysis what's going on here so i mean
we've got
let's see i mean normally
okay in a full multi-computational
picture
every event is for itself so to speak
and if we have like a a list of you know
we have a whole hyper graph full of of
of nodes
every node and every sort of cluster of
nodes gets updated independently that's
kind of the multi-computational way
what we're doing here is we're saying
there is a specific ordering and this is
related to our graph
graph traversal stuff there's a specific
ordering in which we're going to visit
these things
but here
you're showing those two different
orders
as kind of space-like separated things
sort of independently coming out of this
expression
that making sense
yes
now the multi-computational version of
this let's just make a bigger one here
okay
um and i assume by the way that i mean
this is nice by the way yeah just to say
um
and i mean i assume that i can give
options here like aspect ratio arrow
two or something
no
you should make that work
the only reason to not have that work
it's just an additional layer of polish
to add
yeah okay fine
because i think this is this is heading
for a system function but isn't there
quite there yet
okay
so let me just understand this
okay another question for people do
people think this is useful for
debugging
or is this still
and what would make it useful for
debugging
not sure
just
it needs to develop something around it
how to use it with some
filtering
because usually it's going to be big
yeah well i mean trace itself
has certain filtering characteristics
but i mean let's just understand this
what is the multi-computational version
of this
because this is two space-like separated
pieces
there or maybe we call them tree-like
separated i don't know but there are two
pieces here
i mean they're really tree-like
separated pieces and i don't quite
understand
i don't understand how they're snarfed
back up into a tree
so there's five minus one
but how does it know that it gets
re-wrapped with a fib there
do you see what i'm saying yeah
yeah i had that question too
this is a drill down right we had this
in the combinator post and do you want
to comment on this
indeed yes
put that function that you were using in
chat
right
how does it remember the fib
yeah how does it remember that it has to
re-wrap this with a fib
see the question
um
are you asking for the implementation or
you know
how we can tell from the picture what is
the
what is it
you know what i'm saying
see here
like this like we lose the fib right
just the five minus one goes to four and
then we get the fit back again
how is that information being kind of
passed along
it's because the default value of trace
original is false if you do trace
original goes to true then it includes
the expressions both before and after
evaluation
okay so if i did the same thing
and i did trace the original arrow
true oops and now right
that correct
maybe i should have smaller one here
right so the node that was previously
unlabeled because just a placeholder
node
now has the original fib of four minus
one
which is the expression before
evaluation
okay so there's a deconstruction process
here everything that's coming out is
being drilled down into
except for these ones right
right
the the round nodes are things that have
subsidiary evaluations
and the square ones are ones that don't
i see that that uh
how the hell do we know that four minus
one i mean it just so happens that four
minus one oh i see that's a that's an
assembled thing because it's good you
can tell by the reconstruction edges
because they're going from a square
to another square
okay
if it was round and had an edge then
you'd know that's an edge for a
deconstruction
but since it's square and has an
outgoing edge it's a reconstruction
okay
okay and i see that the fibs are
literally being passed now okay yeah i
see that
so let's look at this one here
three minus one okay check its sub
elements
okay it's just three minus one
there's nothing to no sub element by the
way i think that it might be worthwhile
to have an option
here to suppress things like this
you know what i'm saying where things
that evaluate themselves
uh yeah what do you think of the name
trace trivial for that
like trace trivial goes to true or false
wasn't it called show original so maybe
it should be show trivial although
that's a little bit weird
what was shown
race original is the name of the option
oh never mind then and the there's
basically
right
so trace original does two things
it compares expressions before and after
evaluation but it also includes things
that trivially evaluate to themselves
so there's effectively an option
trace trivial that has the same value as
trace original
i don't really like trivial i think i
think nobody no this there's nothing
trivial about this picture um
i think something like uh if you could
set that to false and have trace
original goes to true
i think that would be more like what you
is the name trace original actually
sensible
yeah
um explain it
it
so there's a second argument of trace
that is a pattern that you compare to
the expressions
and by default it's only comparing that
pattern to expressions after evaluation
so trace original also pattern matches
against the original expression before
evaluation
okay well i mean look for the wfr
function trace trivial is i don't know
um
but an additional behavior is that it
does this thing where it includes things
that evaluate to themselves which you
may want one but not the other like they
should be independent look trace
self-evaluation
arrow true or false maybe
it's kind of like self-loops you know i
don't know
i i prefer trace self-evaluation
any comments or not suggestions for that
is self is self-evaluation already taken
or something
i don't think we want to use it for this
this is the i i think that that could
mean no it isn't but it could mean many
things
yeah okay okay but so fine so then that
will that will remove some of the pieces
here but otherwise and by the way that
same option could be supported by trace
absolutely
absolutely i mean trace look the
understanding what the heck trace
actually does
is you know is so obscure at this point
um
i mean it's kind of an interesting way
of showing how the evaluator works
what's a good example that shows
sort of the evaluator
i mean if we say f of
2 plus
1 plus g of
4 plus 6
my god
okay
it's kind of showing how the evaluator
works
possibly even mildly useful
again i don't like it would be nice if
we could annotate
a deconstruction and a reconstruction
edge separately do you see what i'm
saying
the two kinds of elections we just need
an idea for
what to
use
right now you can tell from the shape of
the parent at of the parent node but
that's subtle
that's very subtle other tags on this
edges like what position was this
that would be useful
um there's not currently but i think
yeah the right thing to do would be for
these
to be tagged with the position
and also things like the label is
is a formatting thing it's not really
accessible as an annotation and it
probably should be
fine so okay so look what we need here
is
okay
what is our
okay first question for nick
is there a sort of a token event
interpretation what is this what is this
graph
in our
lexicon of types of graph
i mean this is the non-multi-way this is
a single way
evaluation graph basically
of which there will be a multi-wave
version correct
it can be
this is basically a sub graph of a multi
wave that only deals with
spatially separated evolution
there is no overlapping
sub expression being evaluated right so
all of them are specially separated so
just a sub graph
right
but okay but but look we've got to we've
got to label two kinds of edges i mean
that so this edge here
this is where we need design i don't
know maybe we can
maybe so we can see if we can get
jeremy or somebody to join us for a
moment
we need to
do our
do our colors again i mean just just so
people know like in the physics project
the the fact that we chose canonical
colors is just super useful
go ahead somebody was going to say
something well i was just going to say
any look i think there are two
there are two slightly confused purposes
of dysfunction one of them is is
debugging and the other one is
sort of it's a picture that lets you
understand how things are evaluated for
some educational value
i mean i think
for example for debugging i think that
having every single you know having
every single property of the evaluator
be represented i think is probably not
useful i think yes
it's probably just going to be confusing
um so i mean i think there's a trade-off
between
comprehensibility and and how many
colors and things we use and i'll note
that at the beginning of everyone's
meetings you spend about 20 minutes
where you say you know okay let's
understand what this function is
actually doing and then you put your you
know the same example and so on so yes
you know i'm not sure it's a good idea
to go further in the you know pedantic
but incomprehensible direction well it
might be helped by having look these
edges
if this had an indication that it was a
drill down edge
and it doesn't even you know these
one thing doesn't help
is that we don't have ports in graphs
right so this plus is actually earlier
than this see what i'm saying right
and um
you know really what we want to indicate
on this edge
is that it is a drill down edge i mean
if it wasn't for the fact that arrows
mean something different on graphs i
would think that the drill down edge and
what how can we represent
this is something being deconstructed
this is something being reconstructed
okay let's let's see if jeremy has an
idea
um
okay let's look at trace tree for a
minute here
um one comment about debugging so
i do use trace for debugging quite
frequently and there are typically two
phases to the problem one is finding the
area of the trace that you are
interested in and then the second phase
is looking at that area
so what i'm wondering is how
can this be changed to help in the first
part
so i think this would have to involve
some sort of openers
do you click
on the area that you know
or perhaps a position finding
when there is a message it's typically
quite fast to find where that message
was emitted in the trace
yes
well it should be very fast if there
isn't a good way to do that right now we
should make one
you know some kind of trace message type
thing which just gives you the the
window around that
uh
you know around where the message was
generated look trace is a super old
function
came from 1990 it was an attempt to
understand you know there's an attempt
to do this basically
okay i agree that the openness thing is
important i believe that openers are
coming to graphs and if that's not part
of the global project list it should be
um
openers and graphs could somebody make
sure that gets added
yes i will
um
okay
so
uh
where was i here i mean
um
so look openers and graphs are not going
to come specifically from this project
this is a good application for openers
and graphs we know we need those for
many purposes
um so you were making a different
comment i think about
i mean the question is is this useful
for seeing sort of the overall flow of a
program i don't think we've tried it for
that yet
it's it's certainly not going to be
useful the level where it's showing you
all the microscopic pieces
right so the output of trace is
typically very large so we need to
be able first to go to the area you are
interested in
right i mean here how do i get it to do
this without showing labels so if i say
f of four
for example
boy how do i get this without all its
labels
how do i get just the graph
there's not an easy way right now
okay there needs to be i don't play well
with options
there needs to be i mean can i just say
graph of this and um
you know graph
what what do i say i'm using the the
tree shape function
which is kind of special because it
wraps around the label
what does this do why didn't this work
giving an aspect ratio here
why didn't that work
what's going on here
okay i don't understand what this is
doing do you understand so that this
needs to be fixed basically
right
yeah options
well i mean it's just not working right
so
okay well anyway okay so how do we get
rid of the the labels here is there any
way to do it because we're going to need
that
you can do vertex shape function goes to
none
and what in the in the
in the re-optioning graph
didn't work
oh try all arrow
oh it's a underscore it's a button right
really is this right for this thing f4
just does a straight line evaluation i
just don't believe it
if you do trace original goes to true
okay that's what we've seen before
so i mean
okay and then what we got to think about
is the multi-way version of this what
does that look like
because that was our original objective
here is to make a multi-way trace
which i suppose
is basically a version
of the evaluator
that has been made multi-way
am i correct
yep
and i think that's what
go ahead well i had some version of it
right
just by doing a writing rules
replacements yes well that's the only
operation
yeah
where we don't have but i think we also
want these uh actual you know
down code evaluation type things as well
so we can just
take this trace graph and
uh i don't know splice it
into a multi-wave graph
where the actual variation happened
okay
so all the replacements are which way
but when we actually
go into the into evaluator
and we just make a trace graph and
splice it back
you can do something like that i see as
you just say
well the replacements and perhaps
right but okay in a list for example the
things that space like separated
okay here i think we have jeremy here
let's do a quick session on on doing
colors
okay
jeremy with us yeah i am yep
okay this is an evaluation
a tracecraft this shows the evaluation
process okay there are two kinds of
edges one where you are drilling down
into this expression and evaluating sub
pieces and the other way you're
assembling up to take those sub pieces
and put them together into the into the
final result does that make sense to you
not really
um
so i get the first one so what do you
mean evaluate up
what i mean is
you've got here you've got g of four
plus six
grind grind grind it turns into g of 10.
now you've got to reassemble that
expression
to be 2 plus 1 plus g of 10.
see
i've got those are the pieces that
reassemble to that expression
and then that expression gets evaluated
by the internal evaluator to give three
there
so our question is we've got three kinds
of edges we've got the deconstruction
edges the reconstruction edges and the
uh evaluation transformation edges
so my question is to think of a clever
way to color those edges or to otherwise
indicate what kind of an edge they are
okay
and how does that relate to the shape
the box shape
well right now
the box shape and color
i mean
this is
a end of the line object that does not
evaluate further
okay yeah all right oh it does not no
i'm sorry that doesn't deconstruct
further
like this one has been deconstructed but
it still can evaluate to something
right this is post deconstruction this
is pre-deconstruction
okay
so i mean maybe we want those to have
different colors maybe we want some way
of indicating
pre versus post how would we indicate
that pre versus post like green versus
red or something i don't know
i'm saying and it's like how do you
indicate
this this thing here is an input this
thing here is an output in some sense
or at least this thing has been
processed unprocessed to processed
i mean i would say maybe unprocessed has
some kind of grayish background to
indicate that it's still
you know shimmering whereas this is more
locked in if you get what i'm saying
comments from people about that i think
that's actually a decent idea this one
is kind of uncertain and in the fog and
this one is more certain
yeah that's how we did with
mathematics and rewriting expressions
but we we usually didn't
reconstruct it deconstruct it we
construct it back we just replaced
everything in place
right so it's like if that in original
expression was just changing
inside of it instead of just
deconstructing it back
to be
adjustable
give me a section
which section
think it's just the first one
almost
here when we just have this column
of changing expression these ones here
yeah
okay so that's showing
which piece boot was active
to do the rewrite
right
and you don't need any
deconstruction reconstruction just
highlight change what changes
and you can collapse everything in
between
without you don't need to show it in the
graph i think
so you're suggesting we can simplify
this graph yeah that would be a nice
option just collapse every
deconstruction construction piece and
just
put the vertex that shows the change in
place
so what would that look like here that
would look like
in this case well there wouldn't be
anything there but but
i mean if i were to do
just
well let's do this list one plus one
two three
you basically could only concert with
that dash thread h evaluation edge
so you don't care about
every any deconstruction you just care
about evaluation events so you highlight
whatever piece was evaluated and at
in the position right and what position
a piece
but i don't understand that look if we
if we have this
we've got two different pieces that get
evaluated
so how do we indicate this
oh just show the whole expression
just show the whole expression with one
piece changed inside of it
but then you're showing it twice i don't
understand how we do that in this case
we've got one place where this goes to
two and that goes to another way that
goes to four is that correct
but it's going to be
maybe not in parallel but sequential in
this case
it's going to wait
by how we would indicate this
did you see what i'm saying i mean i
understand how we indicate this
this thing is lit up here this thing is
lit up here how do we know which of
those leads to which thing here
is different highlighting colors or
something
no we're not that's never gonna work i
mean look the perfect way to do it would
be this has an ordering
okay if we had ports we could just have
the output
be based on those ports
otherwise
yeah but look i don't understand nick i
don't understand this because each piece
here
yeah in this case we're doing one
element at a time
and i agree with you that this type of
of indication
of what's going on here is fine but then
it'll look just like this
it'll just show
this is what happened at each step and
much of what's there once you drill down
like this this step here one plus one
goes to two
it's never going to show that sub piece
on its own it's just gonna show one plus
one that's red then the next step it's
two become a two plus two three and and
so on it's going to be a series of it's
gonna be a sequential i mean it's a
worthwhile thing for us to have maybe
you could build that nick
um something where you're seeing the
evaluation process just one step at a
time where each
well what's happening is each
evaluation is just being lit up
does that make sense
yep
stephen can you do trace graph of like
fold of f comma x comma
range of five
so this is an example where you have
subsidiary evaluations that are not just
sub expressions
of the expression
right the fold of f comma x comma list
one two three it has three subsidiary
evaluations
but none of them are sub expressions
that can be highlighted
i see because it generated code on the
fly
right
right okay let's just tackle the thing
with jeremy okay so so in each case
we've got a before and after
right we need a before color we need an
after color
we also have a
this edge here
that is a drill down edge and we have a
reconstruct up edge
who has an idea for visually how to
indicate that
wouldn't before and after take care of
that do you need edges on top of
coloration for before and after
i feel like you're going to get what you
need with just the nodes
possibly possibly it's just not not
dramatic enough with what ian has done
with rounding and square maybe that's
what we need and it's the third color
that's transitional like the the between
what you had shown these pieces that's
some third transitional color that's a
color where it's actually doing
something right that's more like an
event
you know that that's the that seems to
me like it should be sort of an orange
event edge of some kind
what do other people think about that
yeah that that's an event yeah it's an
orange
usually but for nodes is that a before
for range three going to and after with
one two three because it's
heading
to this next node
then after going to another after
okay
that's not necessarily an after because
there could be further evaluation there
as there is in the case of fold
the coincidence you know that could have
gone to something that was round and did
need further but list one okay let's
take a look at what that does in a
particular case so let's say
we say here
uh
you know nest list
hash plus one ampersand
zero two
okay i claim that is going to give
boy evaluations of complicated business
okay so does that
have a subsidiary
yeah that goes to zero plus one exactly
so this orange
goes to an unfinished thing
okay we're going to have this mechanism
where where you where um we say
trace self-evaluation
goes to false if trace self-evaluation
is false
this thing ends there so then it would
go to a
a an output
you know
a
a drilling is finished
type expression right
yep
i give the zero plus one that's round
and the zero plus one that's square
and you would collapse them into just
one node that's square yeah exactly
right but but that would be something
where
i mean so it just needs its color for
the it was finished
and i'm not totally sold on the fact
that these are just gray edges but it
might be right
um okay so the it's finished color
versus the it's still hot
you see what i'm saying
i mean maybe that's the way we should
think about it it's still hot versus
it's over
jeremy what do you think about that some
kind of pinkish color for this
and then this is a bluish color or
something
that makes sense but some of these the
before is
you said gray no i i'm changing my mind
about that okay all right
um
okay
so then this becomes orange sort of a
bright orange event color this becomes
you know it's still pink it's still
embers like the orange on the right
on the right
i don't think it's quite the same orange
okay it's it's more in orange that is
our token event graph our yellow color
but we don't want yellow it's good
because it's a thin thing so jeremy
should spec it
okay let's continue because we've got by
the way it's also got to work when it is
small
um
um uh it's got to work when it goes
small like this
but hopefully it will i mean where where
the um
i mean i don't know the vertex shape
function
yeah i mean it just where it just goes
down i don't know what the what the
options are here and whether you should
say trace labeling arrow true or false
or something
making sense
and it's it's just like your unlabeled
tree idea i feel like vertex labels
a vertex
label goes to none should just work
that's fine
that's fine
but then that that's going to need to be
a different color spec for that
what was this again
it's a placeholder
what does that mean what would for
jeremy's purposes what color should that
be
the same as the square
or the rectangular
so what does that mean again
that means there's
that's a form in the subsidiary
evaluation
that's
from a reconstruction
but it doesn't match the pattern that
you specified
so there's just a placeholder there okay
it doesn't match this pattern of what
we're looking at right but it is
necessary it is an expression which will
be used again
to make
this result which is a five or something
or whatever it is down here
but we're not showing the fives because
we're only showing the underscore fib
uh
expressions that got generated right
okay so i think that's a different color
and i think that color should be some
kind of gray color that indicates
because we're never going to have a
pre-evaluation version of this are we
yes
what is the aspen when yes we're not
going to have a
version
there are pre-evaluation versions
they're small circles
i see so okay so this then has the same
colors the blue and the pink color
all right okay
can we move on here let's look at trees
i'm not sure if jeremy's gonna be needed
for this what what is trace tree could i
show you what i've got because i'm not
fully following all of this
i shouldn't let you sure yeah i could
share for a second
okay roughly kind of the pre
to the post
to the evaluated and then
i left these as the wrong way i wasn't
sure one way around okay so let's so
that
the pre is still hot
okay
um
i'll just do it quickly and choose
better colors
okay the post
there is cold
okay
and that 10
yeah the 10 is still hot and maybe that
reddish color is actually not a bad
color
now this was how it related to these two
well anything that's square
is
anything that's square is cold
right guys
and that means we rounded
that would mean that there'd be two
colors
not three
correct there are two colors not three
and the other red one would be
orange
those would all be blue
yeah okay
but i still then think that the
reconstruction edges
are
um
okay so that 10
if you could you just make the other
things at the top that same red color
sure
no not not the plus not the plus stop
plus
i don't know oh yeah that's gonna i was
going to pull it out yeah
okay
i mean i think scholars are not quite
the right colors no no i just wanted to
get the right kind of things labeled
properly
which
the tin
the red tin should be blue
so it's pretty weird that the four plus
six
it's cold
but then okay so if you just solid
solidify that line the evaluation line
there that's currently dotted
i think that again needs to be a
somewhat intense
thing there that's somewhat thick
oh i mean if it's too difficult
don't worry about it
um
okay bright and thick for that line i
would say okay
um
hey talking of designs with the wrong
set of people here but but did you work
on the quantum framework stuff jeremy
billy did yeah he's got a good start to
it i think he was working with them to
make sure it's the right direction okay
all right
what do we think about this this
collaboration i think i think we're
well it's it
it's better
um if you're not distinguishing if
you're distinguishing by a color now are
you going to continue to keep the
different vertex shapes or they're going
to be the same
same shape
right
um
but i i don't i'm still not clear that
these edges all should be quite exactly
the same
what could you indicate how could you
indicate an edge drill down versus
assemble together
just in the in in a decoration to the
edge
you use the same color as the
node that it's coming from
no that's not right because that look at
those look at in the four plus six
section
right there are deconstruction edges and
there are reconstruction edges
and they don't have
you know
you could
come from a red node and the
reconstruction come from blue nodes
so i feel like deconstruction
being added reconstruction being blue
makes sense
we had also discussed edges that
increase or decreasing in width
so we couldn't agree in which direction
it went
because to me this is assuming effect so
i was expecting the
deconstruction is increased
size
oh i was thinking the other way i see
zooming in
okay
well jeremy could try that but but um
i'm not sure if it will look sensible
i mean
okay so the suggestions on the table are
to put a slight red tinge
on the deconstruction edges
i think that might be the simplest thing
to try doing
and then really that transformation edge
is a much thicker brighter thing
dot it could work for these guys it's
this kind of breaking apart
which makes dotted makes more sense for
me
on deconstruction right we can try it
but i think
you know possibly
i just think it's going to be dotted all
over the place i mean we could have
dotted and dashed in a very samuel morse
kind of way
um there
uh
you know
dotted for deconstruction dashed for
reconstruction i think it's gonna look
silly though to have so much darting and
dashing around the picture if it's a
large graph
gonna be able to discriminate between
the two
no we should not care if it's a large
graph
why
because
look if the edges are colored you'll
still be able to tell that if it's a
large graph yes you might yes even if
and even if the vertices aren't labeled
you should be able to tell that
that's true all right well look let's
try a couple of those things all right
let me share again this is looking good
it was getting there
i mean these are
um
okay explain trace tree for a second
so trace graph is showing the
relationships between the expressions
themselves
in an evaluation
trace tree is showing the hierarchy of
the evaluation chains
so one subtree equals one complete
evaluation chain
what
is this some kind of unrolling of the
graph above where things are not shared
again or what
right
so this is essentially a depth first
traversal of the graph above is that
true
i'm not sure
i mean this is showing essentially the
recursion tree
for the thing that does have edges
and and
you know the passage of time is
indicated by siblings like you go from
one sibling to the next
and there aren't edges depicting that
i understand but then you recurse what
is the recursion here
it is it is isn't it i mean this is this
you see the oneplus one and it goes to
two
yeah i get it i get it that that's um so
that's the evaluation
so that's the evaluation event is right
there
right but this says so what this is
showing i think
is the is the execution process of the
evaluator
recurse
recall the evaluator i claim a dot is a
recursive call to a vowel
what do people think about that claim
so this is this like round nodes are the
beginning of
a subsidiary evaluation right so it's a
recursive chord evaluator yeah but so
you see there's a fib of three minus one
plus fib of three minus two
yes
yep
that is deconstructed into those next
two children
i understand so that the flow of
reconstructed into the oneplus one
yeah i understand this is this is a this
is a stack trace basically this is an
execution history of the evaluator i
claim where history is going this way it
goes from this to this to this
and in fact it goes
well i'm a little bit confused by this
but this
fiber three
no where the heck does filler three
that's
original goes to true
it's the same thing
that we saw earlier where there's a
three and it mysteriously turns into a
fib of three
now this is actually showing what
happens
okay fib of three
but it doesn't turn into this i mean
what i'm understanding is that the
horizontal
axis here
i'm confused anybody not confused here
i'm confused hopefully ian's not
confused yeah aside from me or okay in
explain
so fib of three
is the root
right that's the original expression
it deconstruct into fib and into three
so those are the round nodes there
then those are reconstructed into fib of
three and that's the leaf fib of three
and then that transforms into the three
minus one plus fib of three minus two
and then that deconstructs into the plus
and the fib of three minus one
and if this seems like a less useful
representation than the one above
or am i missing something
the purpose of this was to be able to
take the output of trace and
put it do expression tree on it
and and this is showing the hierarchy of
complete evaluation chains from start to
finish
the graph one is showing the
relationships between
individual expressions
so if i were to do
my friendly version of this
oh my god
get rid of the graph
which
do you mean get rid of the golf thing
you haven't breath
oh i see
but can i say vertex shape function to
none
as possible
you have to put tree around it and use
tree options
what are the three options here
see what it does without options first
with uh just tree element label goes to
all goes to none
i guess you could also just apply
unlabeled tree to this
then you then you lose the round and
square
i don't think they're helping me very
much
they mean different things no i
understand they mean different things
but so this is now
so if we did this for fibonacci
what the heck is this tree
so why are these things so absolutely
huge that's just wrong
i have the impression that
sorry i have an impression that this is
a more faithful representation of what
trace
returns
okay but why are these dots so
ridiculously huge
ian it's wrong right what why did i
don't understand
they they have a fixed size they
shouldn't
right this is clearly wrong
i mean how have we done this for grass
no an unlabeled tree they do not have a
fixed size
i believe that's just the default
okay it's wrong
eyes from grass it's clearly wrong you
do recognize that it's wrong right
now you can see that it's wrong here
do you agree what's wrong i do not agree
it's wrong
apply graph to it
that's super ugly
why are they so big
i don't know
oh we should find out i mean
who's project managing here
who's project manager i am kristen
okay so it's for you can you take that
to charles please find out what wrong
sigh
okay
okay let's while we're at it let's just
take a look
at
this you know
like f of 5 here
just to get some sense
i don't know you know
when in doubt make it bigger
my god
that's funky
i mean i don't even understand the
fibonacci tree here
let alone i mean when in doubt make it
bigger let's try fib7
okay what the heck is going on here
and what would this look like
multi-computationally go ahead
i'm saying i would need the labels
the full labels
my memory can certainly get
i'm not going to do that
and you also have to get rid of trail
mill label yeah i know
you can do it but it's going to make a
big mess right
um we've got we're running out of time
here and i really want to look at a
couple other things
but um
uh and i would like to okay can we have
a very very quick look at some next work
here please
um
well briefly it's just uh
a backlit
that
i
implemented all the pattern objects with
the pattern matching with some
intermediate
thing for replacement so it's like a
detailed replacement
where you first do a part of marching
it's what's returned by the spot on
substitutions and then you can extract
all the bitings and
use it like in all the replacement
functions for example
so you're saying
this is
how things were bound
and
you could just apply those bindings to
the original expression to get the
result you would get that correct
not the original to the if you had a
rule you applied to the right right hand
side yes
yeah
that's a nice thing
that's a nice thing now did you have to
rewrite you know did you have to
re-implement the pattern match it and to
make this work yeah it's like i
implemented all of it so it's like a
level two pattern match here i used
pattern matching to implement all
the parts of my chin again
okay
this is a very interesting thing i mean
this should be a built-in function of
some kind i think i mean does
uh christopher or anybody else have a
comment on this
i mean we should have had this like 30
years ago this you know lists the
bindings
this works with arbitrary patterns
yeah
almost all of them implemented like
maybe
some
bugs still there but yeah
is it just implemented with replace
basically
no you can implement any function with
it it's like python substitution is the
big function here
right i just mean that it's
it's implemented like replaces is how
this function is internally implemented
right i'm just i'm guessing
yeah
it's like
have a handler for all the primitive
pattern objects like all pattern
sequences except alternative
blanks so
what the heck is this
yeah it's like this one looks very ugly
especially with this
big context
what is their walk from patterns
substitution sum what is that
well if you open the link is there a
link to actual pocket there's some
documentation
what are the top
oh hold on let me just
vegetarian
this
is this relevant to the to compilation
with patterns
i don't think so i mean it's just
calling replace it's basically wrapped
around a place then yeah
where's the um is that
the guide
okay
boy this is cool this is a real paclet
so the first is like three heads that i
use for the object itself i don't format
it yet but it can be just like formatted
with some nice summary books
but the substitution like can be one of
those four things
it's like query algebraic
can i see
pattern substitutions
there are many
a lot of information inside of it you
should be able to use this object in
order to reconstruct your expression
back from your pattern
and also extract all the bindings from
it
okay
by the way point for kristen there's a
stupid bug with the formatting here
right
i don't really understand this yet
but this isn't this you claim this is an
algebraic representation
of
what i mean this is some kind of
compiled representation of the pattern
that right
it's a compiled representation of a
substitution of a pattern matched
against an expression it's like after
you're applying python matcher to an
expression it extracts the information
and it knows where
what all the bindings are where i had
which
button object being matched to something
and so on like
so that you can actually construct the
expression back
all possible with instructions so it's
like a quest list you can
implement your post listed
i see so this is a multi-way object
yeah sum is basically the outer head is
alternatives
and the product is like all the
like all the
substitutions that applied at a single
instance
so if we were doing category theory this
would be some kind of monoidal category
thing in the outside
well it's more like a ring i think it's
just because you have a
two type of
it's like an algebra you have a summer
product it's a product a co-product
and you can even
interpret part
position as some kind of
scalar multiplication maybe
it's cool
are you sure this isn't relevant to the
to the compiler
to compiling sort of the process of
pattern matching
because like well
yeah i mean let me think
maybe it could be in the sense of uh
that you basically use the
evaluator to get this sort of uh
this representation of the pattern and
then that's what the compiler actually
uses if you want to run you know i don't
know match queue or something
yes and basically the question is if
this can get a representation of the
pattern it's easier to
you know compile supernova matricu on it
then the normal representation of
patterns then maybe it could be useful
for that
um
but i'm not sure that's exactly i'm not
sure that's entirely the problem with
patterns in the compiler honestly i
think the main problem with planning
compiler is just that um
the way they were initially implemented
was not thought through
and so i think it's
right i think that there haven't really
been many attempts since then so i think
there may be it may be possible to do a
more sane attempt and it will be fine
but
yeah this is like this is the attempt
also if you open the tutorial page i
have this little small collection of
differences with the current
this much replacement
inside where there's some differences
with the current part of my chair
the difference between this and you know
so this will give one answer and match q
will do something else
yeah or maybe there's like some yeah
are these differences where you think
that that
that your version does the right thing
and the pattern matcher does the wrong
thing or
are they just different in some of it in
some of it but debatable
well what are there let me see are are
there any examples
match
of a null list and a list with a blank
period
i don't see why it doesn't return true
that seems like a bug
yeah
well then maybe we should report that i
mean like if it's an actual bug
okay yeah like i also went through some
bugs
that i reported and also some other
packs that they
found related to parcel matching somehow
nick i have a feeling that you you know
it's time to put on that that diving
gear or something and go look at the
actual pattern natural source code
maybe luck
i'm afraid yeah
um
sounds like part of the thing is the
pattern matcher i mean
yeah i mean whenever i've looked at
parametric code it ends up being super
super complicated largely because i mean
the base functionality usually is not
that complicated then they're edge cases
and in particular they're edge cases and
things like attributes and that just
like
kills you because it's just you know you
now have to handle every combination of
attributes
right but i mean when i originally wrote
this code and i think it survived one of
the main things i did was i looked at
all these different cases where i
thought there were you know
optimizations for particular cases and i
literally numbered you know cases where
the different types of things would
happen where you would you know be sort
of combinatorially enumerating with
respect to one index versus another and
so on
so it's broken into just an immense
number of different cases
which is
you know not i mean it was i think it's
good for efficiency it's not great for
maintainability
um
well this is really interesting and we
should look at this some more and um i
know we've got i really need to get
going but but um i just want to know
what a branch of wormhole is
and then
i just want to look at this one
um
right well these are all important
things i i think we need to follow up
with another meeting in this series
preferably sooner than a week because we
got this is an active thing we've got
lots of stuff nick your moment to
explain branch of wormholes
really quick right
okay
so this is a very close to the event
branchograph for the multi-way system
it's a branchograph
built on top of a causal graph
but it takes into account
this nature of events it's like if you
have an actual space like separated
events you don't care you don't connect
them with a branch of edge you only
connect events that are actually
overlapping so so that they don't
commute with each other i see
so they like start to represent
this correlation
and okay so this is overlaying a piece
of branchial graph
on top of
i don't understand why i mean isn't it
it's like some of these events
you could indicate that they are
branchially separated as opposed to
space-like separation is that correct
yes
so it's annotating this graph
with um
uh with branch shield
like
separation
yeah and then is this a pruned version
of this graph somehow
well one of them only contains events
and another one with states too i see i
see i see it so this is
this is annotating which
events are branch-like separated
yeah
and then you
and then all those branches of edges
they also because they represent
correlation some non-local correlation
between events they kind of slide
through the causal edges
right because all the events that
causally depend on the events that
branchly connect also should be
branching connected
so
as soon as you connect them you slide
them through the
causal edges into the future
and that's the this branch of graph
that represents all the local
correlations
between events
so this is this is the true sort of this
is the quantum and tank you know this is
the
this is some version of quantum
you know this is non-spatial
relationship between two events yeah
okay
okay what's this thing
oh that's this is after you slide it
through the causal edges
so this is essentially annotating the
causal graph with which
causal edges are on different threads of
time basically
which which yeah which events rather
are
on distinct
threads of time is that right so any
anything that's connected by a branchial
edge
can't
occur
on the same thread of time
basically why not i think it can
because when you have a
overlapping event
that's
when we connect them those events
right and it can happen at one
particular moment
i'm fairly confused try again well
usually
usually if there's a branchial edge
between you know two states right
they're not time like separated that's
the whole point
yes right
so
that's what you're showing here is the
things which are not
which can't be time like separated
but wait a minute can they be
and they're also not space-like
separated is that correct
well they're overwhelming here that's
the whole point but we're starting with
overlapping events but then we
just move forward this correlation
forward
you can also think of this branch of
edges they kind of constraint your
foulation because they connect events
that are
supposed to are not commissioned so we
can't follow them they
should be in the one particular
ovulation space
they have to be in the same foliation
slice you're saying
yeah because if you were in different
ones you already
assume an affiliation that one falls
another one
right
but that's different from saying
i'm confused if two things are space
like separated
there are multiple foliations that
preserve that space like separation
yeah
but here you can't make one you
basically when you have two overlapping
events
you don't know which foundation is
correct one because
whatever you pick
changes your history right because
they're not convenient so both relations
are correct and you can't just pick one
of them
so it's like it's like two multiverses
say that again you will have two
universes
right as soon as you have an
overwrapping event it's branching
and you just represent it with one
branch of edge
between those i see
and that's why you're calling this a
branchial wormhole
yeah it's because it connects two
universes basically
this branchial edge
is the connection between two distinct
universes with different histories
is that correct
yeah and if you just look at it like
that it connects events
because you can actually compute the
distance in the causal graph usually
right by longest path in the causal
graph
time distance and space distance but if
you have this branch of edge your
effective distance going to be smaller
because you have this additional
correlation between those
yes
hence
you know spooky action and distance and
quantum mechanics and other such things
yep
so your point is
there is a this is pretty nice there is
a
notion of this construction of space
time
that has certain distances between
events
but
what you're doing is you're annotating
that by branchial connections between
events
which are
sort of on different threads of the
multiverse so to speak
um
and
which may be nearby in branchial space
but far away and causal space so to
speak
in space time yeah
yes
and so
so these things so that's why you're
calling them branch or wormholes
it's because this is
that's
that is the
giving sort of
worm holy reality
to the sort of claim of quantum
mechanics
that
um
right can you interpret it specifically
in terms of of um
uh epr
well this is
wormhole and it's entanglement
i think that's what it shows right
well this is an entanglement edge yes
this shows entanglement
connects events in space time so it's
actually
it's like a wormhole
yeah that's pretty cool
okay so your point is this is both the
quantum
uh correlation in the epr sense
and a space-time
sort of connection in the er sense
yep
that's interesting
nick in your community post did you
mention er equals epr
uh i don't think so you should write a
bulletin on that that would be really
cool
yeah and also the question would be
in the er equals epr
kind of so you're you're
basically you're claiming this picture
shows that er equals epr
well at least some it shares some
intuition yeah right i mean you might be
able to make a bigger version of this
where you can actually see
the development of a um
uh and i think jonathan had some
sprinkling way of getting
you know
a space-time wormhole
and if you can do that
you might be able to see that
uh
you know that there's a necessary
connection between the multi-way part of
this
the branchial part of this and the
space-time part of this
yeah this is a very nice thing
and even though
the term branchial wormhole which is
perfectly good term for this takes a few
steps to understand i think
um
i think i mean if i were explaining this
i would talk about there's a multi-way
causal graph and we're annotating the
multi-way causal graph by adding you
know just like we can annotate a
multi-way graph by adding causal edges
so we can annotate further by adding
branchial edges in fact is that
something we've done
given
you know given a graph given a multi-way
graph
we annotate it by adding causal edges
but we could also annotate it by adding
branchial edges could we not
yeah we can i think that was my first
summer school project
when i try to
show it in 3d also
oh yeah i vaguely remember this yes i do
remember this so that's
right which is also somewhat related
things i was trying to do with
multi-space
but what you what you're saying is there
is a
the
you know the multi-way causal graph is
not the end of the road
the end of the road
i mean the multi-way graph is in a sense
what's really there the multi-way causal
graph is an annotation of the multi-way
graph
and then
the multi-way branchial causal graph
is the full
is the full enchilada well actually it
isn't even the full one because there's
even the real version of that
but that's you know that's at least a
fair distance of the way there and so
then the claim would be that you know uh
the holographic principle and things
they have to do with projections in that
graph
yeah that's a cleaner way to think about
it actually than than to actually
construct that fully annotated graph
with both causal edges and branchial
edges and then to say
as you look at the ads or cft direction
you're basically filtering that graph to
look at only one kind of edges
that seems like a reasonable way to
think about it and then the question is
really
if for simple cases what does that graph
look like for example are there are
there simple uh you know underlying
evaluation rules evolution rules that
lead to just some simple grid graph like
i had some pictures of good graphs where
there's time-like directions
space-like direction and branchial
direction
but it would be really nice to actually
explicitly construct such a such a
combined
time space well essentially
you know
multi-way evolution
causal and branchial
graph
and then you know and then see which one
what we can get from simple underlying
rules for that graph because we may be
able to see for example it may be
obvious
that cpt invariance for example follows
that that there's a invariance principle
i mean we know that cpt invariance is
related to rotations in that
you know branch shield causal etc space
but it may be totally obvious from this
graph that you know in some limit of
sort of computationally irreducible
randomized limit of that graph that it
necessarily is the case that cpt
invariance exists
that would be nice
at least approximate cpt and variance
and then of course the
oh boy that would be interesting i mean
you know we need a signature okay
we're off on a different topic here but
i mean we need
in extreme gravitational situations it's
not obvious that cpt invariance is still
valid and this would show how that
breakdown of cpt invariance might happen
which is relevant because
it might lead to observable consequences
among other things
all right this is really nice okay for a
different time um let's try and schedule
something soon and we might want to
break these
uh you know the physics discussion of
that and by the way if you were able to
make some samples of that they could
combine that combined graph it'd be
really nice
um
from we need a sort of separate meeting
about this pattern compilation stuff i
think
because the pattern compilation stuff is
working towards the multi function is it
not
no
maybe
but the main point is this is all
multi-way
yeah it's like it's a replace list also
which way but this is just
much away with additional information
with more details
right fully tagged so that it can have
causal graphs and things like this which
replace list cannot
i mean this presumably you could make
causal graph based on this if i'm
understanding correctly
yeah you can
deconstruct all this substitution object
and extract all the things that it
actually uses
in theory
yeah right
cool all right a lot of wonderful stuff
here i think i mean look these
developments on er equals epr adsc cft
cpt and variance i mean i think the
institute especially with the physics
project i mean we should just start
working on all of this stuff this is all
super exciting yeah yes it is
it is
very nice well done
well done
and perhaps
proving er equals epr
yeah that's pretty wpp it's pretty good
for one meeting man
okay um
all right gotta go to a different
meeting which is also being live
streamed for those following that um all
right but if we can get something
scheduled to continue with this sooner
rather than later that would be great
and um uh and for ian getting that
recoloring stuff and some of those
additional options would be wonderful
yep
okay thanks